America's insists on being first in
everything first and well first in
military might first in the buffet line
first and cholesterol but since we don't
innovate anything important anymore we
now put most of our brain power into
devising increasingly insane foodstuffs
that we can shove in our patriot holes
which of these is a new real food you
can actually buy at an American Ballpark
a funnel cake sandwich a barbecue pulled
pork fried onion shredded cheddar
Monterey Jack cheese bacon and a
jalapeno skewer
well everyone just got diarrhea hearing
laughs I should have given you pepto
before I even read that or a deep-fried
meatball sub on a glazed cronut button
called the hoagie bara knows real
Kristen Schaal yeah but they're both
pretty good options but I'm gonna let
the Hobie Bera that actually sounds like
the good one it's not if the first one
is real yep this is Kansas City's
Kauffman Stadium now offering the pulled
pork patty melt a deep-fried mass and if
you squint I'm pretty sure looks like
Guy Fieri with a shirt off though bacon
so the first ever food model on the
cancer it causes will be about it should
have a little mountaineer on the side
yeah oh yeah oh yeah coming up the side
you know there's just there's just camps
of people who couldn't make it to the
top and the base guy at the bottom
eating a small version of Anna
[Music]
[Applause]